hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i train
thousands of people in property nick is
one of those people
he came to the crash course the free
crash course with 10 pounds in his
pocket
originally from nepal being a soldier in
afghanistan
came back from afghanistan came to the
crash course with 10 pounds his pocket
he's now financially independent
he's 22 years old now incredible
incredible story
so nick thank you so much for coming
down to my home office my pleasure it's
my pleasure thank you very much
and and it's just so good to see what
you've done and i know you've gone on to
do some further training you're on the
samuel 365 you've done the online deal
finding extravaganza
um but but but before we get to where
you are now
give me a lowdown into your backstory
and
and and your your kind of history your
childhood because
you did definitely not come with a
silver spoon in your mouth
no definitely not so yeah about 2017
so that's the year when i got in
enlisted in british army
so after that i came in uk to british
army
then we did a one-year training in
catrick after that i had few tours uh
exciting kenya then afghanistan then i
was
browsing few videos and i come up with
your video i think the guy with in
blackpool finding some freedom
yeah so i watched a few videos and read
your books
then i came into crash course i came
into crash course
and yeah i attended two days crash
course then i started
calling agents from next day i started
calling agents and did few viewings
and luckily i got my first deal on
january
so yeah that deal was quite challenging
because of the kovid
and how did you how did you get that
deal because when we
met first you just got back from
afghanistan
as a soldier yeah and you had 10 pounds
to your name
is that correct yeah that's correct so
how did you go from having 10 pounds
to getting a deal like what was the deal
what were the figures how did that
happen that's
great and i know since then you've gone
on to get a lot more deals
but how did you get that first deal what
happened so yes firstly
i watched few of your uh rain to hatch
them up videos as well and
winners on wednesday the guys who did
hatchimal yeah and i
watched that video again and again to
find out what exactly how i can get my
first property
and then i kept on viewing and when i
started
using the script i get no no no from
most of the agent no
then i found i think i'm doing some kind
of mistake over here
then i watched the video again and i
found the script that you are
using and i use that script and i
got my property but i had no money for
to put the rent first my rent and
deposit
so i applied for the loan then i took
the loan money and i put it in my first
property
how much was the loan so the loan was 9
000 pounds
okay big risk right exactly and and some
people would say
don't do it you know you've got no money
you're you've just got back from
afghanistan from the army
you know you've been watching samuel's
videos you've been to some of his
courses
don't go and get a loan that's risky and
they tell you not to do it
exactly did anyone say that to you did
you what were your friends and your
family and your associates and your
what were they all saying when you were
doing this did they think it was great
or were they concerned oh definitely not
no so
like uh they used to tell me no don't do
it it's a risky
you might lose your money however you're
going to pay the loan back don't don't
step in
just do whatever you are doing it's fine
we like the way you are
so this kind of stuff there yeah try and
protect you yeah trying to correct me
yeah that's always what happens
yeah exactly yeah yeah so but anyway so
from my inside uh i really wanted to do
this uh property journey i want to
i really wanted to study this but yes
and i took my step
and i took the loan then i started my
journey in property so that first
that first property yeah uh where is it
so it's in oxford town
in london yeah in london in london uh
yes uh we did three four
meetings with the same agent like he
wasn't convinced with me because that
was that was my first property yeah and
he was though he was like in the middle
50 50 chances were there
and so i i had to use i had to persuade
him
as mentioning him that yeah we're going
to take care of the property we're going
to do the inspection
so this kind of stuff and yeah he was
happy to give me the property
right so because of course i'm just
trying to think
credit wise did you have good credit
credit
it was it was you can say good because
whatever amount i had before 10 pound i
invested everything back in nepal sure
but unfortunately that
that didn't went well yeah so i was left
with 10 pounds what's your citizenship
nepal
yes i have nepal so i'm just trying to
put myself
in your shoes as from last year and from
and in the shoes of the estate agents
from someone who's just taken out a loan
yeah who's never
got any experience in property um 21
years old at the time yeah
not a uk citizen no saying
i want to take on a property i'm just
trying to work out you must have you
must have used some serious skills
to get that deal so yeah i i've done few
uh sales training as well yeah how to
persuade people what kind of words you
use
talking with people so yeah i used
everything whatever i learned
yeah and i was able to get the property
it's so important that you say that
because i think that
property business is a people business
it's not just a numbers game it's also
about being able to communicate to
persuade people
um okay great so you got a loan you used
your sales
skills to get an agent to give you a
rental deal you found the deal based on
the training that you had from myself
yeah um and then what happened what
happened to the property
uh so as in so they were still in doubt
whether this guy can
do it or not and they were even as
doubtful as your friends right yeah yeah
my friends yeah
but anyway so yes i learned where to
advertise the rooms
and within a week i rented all the rooms
yeah and as in
the agent they were very impressed and
they were offering the job in their
company wow hey respect thank you very
much i'm good i'm an entrepreneur thanks
so that property then how much were you
paying to the landlord
each month so i was paying uh 2200
2 200 pounds yeah you don't live in
london no i don't live in where do you
live
so at that time i was living in foxton
which is two hour drive from there
okay what about now where do you live i
live in wells in wales yeah
why you keep moving around everywhere
what's happening so because of the army
they keep posting me
yes so i was in focusing for two years
now for next two years i'll be in wells
so you're still working full-time in the
army yeah exactly so you're doing all
this on top of your job
yes so mainly on weekends what
so how many hours a week are you working
in the army
mostly 95 it depends but because we need
to be ready at any time they might call
up
so you've got a full-time demanding job
yeah you had no money not a british uk
citizen no
english is your second language yes
that's correct but you managed to secure
this deal
you're paying the landlord you've
committed to pay 2 200 a month
how much were you renting the property
out when you turned into a hmo
so i was getting in total 4000 from this
property
okay so i was making quite good cash
flow from this property what was the
monthly
profit after all your costs after all my
car it was
uh 9050 pound 950. so almost decided
almost a thousand pounds profit yeah
from that one property
yes that's correct very very good thank
you then the pandemic came yeah
that did not slow you down what happened
so yes this prop
this property i can't complain but i can
take it as my learning curve yeah
so pandemic came and the two my two
rooms
the people they moved out yeah because
they cannot afford the rent and they
moved out
so i had few challenges in this pandemic
i did quite a lot of viewings but
as you know the pandemic was silenced no
no people no one knows no one was moving
so i um i did sometime length let's
and i i did for only a week then only a
month so this is how i
managed to pay the rent short term last
year okay cool like like uh
you put it on what on airbnb oh no and
spare room
advertising that we are happy to do so
you were just getting people quick short
term lets
so you you had to adapt your strategy
yeah did it continue making profit
so no it was very challenging i wasn't
making profit i was only able to pay the
rent and the bills
so it's literally breaking even yeah so
as a result of that a lot of people at
this point would have said the pandemics
come
i got this property it was making 950
pounds profit a month
now it's making nothing it's just
breaking even yeah
i think i'm just gonna stick to my job
and i wish i hadn't got the loan out
samuel leeds is okay he's a good guy but
forget this i'm done that's what a lot
of people would have done
what did you do so yeah i had this voice
in my head so kids leave it it's too
risky you can't do this kind of job
you need to call people and it's very
risky how you're going to pay the rent
so yeah this voice this little voice was
still in my in my it was in my head and
i used to
chat with my wife and she used to say
okay don't worry just give a go
you have come so you have you have you
came this far don't give up
so all right i still continued and yeah
during this pandemic i was able to pay
the rent
and the bills so after the pandemic we
had a
gap so in that moment i rendered the
room again
so back in that same cash flow we
started getting the same cash flow
right and within two months i secured
two properties
and all the properties are rented
maximum within two weeks i rent all the
properties
now my fourth property is i just took uh
on
november mid of november now everything
is gone
october sorry october yeah yeah october
now everything is gone
now i'm looking for new property at the
moment okay
so you've got your first property yeah
it took a little bit of a hit
yeah it went down to make breaking even
washing its face
you had a bit of patience yeah adapted
it then became profitable again yeah
gave you confidence
yes you then decided to go get another
three properties yes that's correct okay
and and were they off the same landlord
differently different landlords so
different agents different agents yeah
different agent and different landlord
i had this property and i got a good
reference from them because i was paying
the rent during the food as well
so i got good reference and yeah because
you stuck it out yeah
and from there i got another property
how much right now with just the four
properties i know you've got your fifth
property
coming soon but with the four properties
that you've got how much
profit after all expenses are you making
off of those four properties
so minimum i'm making 600 pound maximum
i'm making
900 pound from one property so that's
going to round our figure it's going to
be 25 something like that
so sorry so six to 900 per month per
property yeah and you've got four
properties yes
so you're making about two and a half
thousand pounds yeah clean profit after
everything a month
that's correct that's very good going
thank you very much very good going
and and how are you juggling how are you
juggling your time in all of this
because you live
in wales yeah the properties are in
london you've got
four you're going for a fifth you told
me you want 10 by march
next year yes that's correct how are you
managing your time
how is this happening so yeah that was a
good question so yeah every weekend me
and my wife we used to drive from wells
to
london for the property and
after that i hired one manager and after
that another guy came in
so right now i have my team including me
we are three people
one guy is doing maintenance and
viewings other guys
checking the documents referencing
tenants and i'm the one
looking for new deals at the moment okay
and are they let's go
sorry sorry you've got three people now
in your team you've employed two people
yeah and you're paying them out of the
profits at the moment
so it's been only a month so they said
they don't want
income they want what they are looking
for the outcome they want to learn about
the property
so they are not after the you're a smart
guy nick
thank you so so you basically put them
on work experience
uh so actually they were matins what
yes that's correct okay and they said
they want to work with me
yeah ask them why you want to work with
it because they said i'm looking to
learn from
looking about to learn to a lot about
the properties from you
and i said okay i'm happy to have you in
my team but you need to have the same
working spirit that i have and we had
few
interviews as well yeah and these guys
they were incredible so they
just instantly want to join my team and
they're working hard so yeah they're
working hard so one guy is busy doing
viewings other guys
looking after new qualifying their
property in the market and
i'm the one doing viewings and dealing
with agents
wow i mean geez i've got to say i'm
incredibly impressed thank you very much
you've done ridiculously well talked
how how how did you do all this give me
the secrets
the only secret is hungry only for goals
yeah so yeah you need to you need to
have set a target
and you just follow it yeah exactly i
mean you must be very hungry
because you had just about every excuse
going for you
i'm busy i've got a job i've got a
demanding job or i might have to work
weekends yeah i haven't got money
i got 10 you had 10 pounds when we met
at the crash course yeah exactly yeah
in the time i uploaded even in my worst
situation i'm doing my best
that was my quote when i uploaded that
picture last december which picture is
that
now the one that i sent initially yeah
one in crass course yeah
this 2019 december yeah so yeah
at the financially i was struggling but
i was learning
self-developing i was learning about the
properties and straight from the crash
course i was a different guy
i now at that time i knew about the
property strategies
how can i work which strategy works for
me so yes i was totally different guy
after the crash course what what
happened at the crash course
that was such a transformation you say
you're a different person
i mean it was just two days like what
happened that was so transformational
so after before going to crash course i
watched few of your videos
and about the properties i got the
puzzle i only got the puzzle piece
pieces so after the crash course you
helped me
to set the pieces and make a good
picture in the puzzle
and i got the tools and strategy and i
got the people around me same kind of
mindset people
would motivate each other to go for a
dream and from there
i said okay everything is normal there's
no difference only back in my
environment where i'm right now is
different for them but for me it's
normal i should start doing this
that's really inspiring and just less
than one year later now
yeah here you are and you i saw your
before and after picture where you were
there
at the crash course like excavating time
you know
yeah like you've got your team behind
you your keys suited and booted
it's an incredible story thank you very
much what is it that gives you that
hunger
what's your strongest reason for doing
all this the strongest reason of
i had financial struggles
back in my home and because our business
didn't went well
and i know how it feels struggling
financially and i would never want to be
in that same situation again in my whole
life
so that's what motivating me what what
happened in nepal that was so
that was so tough financially what
happened so in nepal we have a family
business
and my father and my brother they were
looking after business
they took a heavy huge amount of loan
for the business to
maintain the business and to take it to
next level but unfortunately they were
able to they weren't able to take the
business next level
and they were struggling to pay the
loans so whatever money i earned from
afghanistan i
everything i helped them yeah and i was
here for i was financially struggling
over here
and i studied in crass course and i took
the loan and took my step
so your family in nepal took a loan
the business didn't go well they ended
up suffering as a result yeah
but then you in england you then decided
to take a loan
yeah that must have been very very um
tough mentally yeah exactly yeah what
do you think you did differently because
i i mean a lot of people in your
situation would have been like i'm never
getting into any debt
and of course there's good debt and
there's bad debt yeah
what was it that gave you the confidence
to go ahead and get that loan out that
got you started in your property
business
uh to be honest i i must uh say
motivation videos
yeah what's motivation videos how to
control your mind how to
go and take risk because they risk in
everything you take
so i i thought why not why not this way
i'll take this risk in this part and
whatever happens i'll see it
well i admire you for that greatly
you're a samuel 365 member as well
yeah talk to me a bit about what that is
and how that might have helped
so yes i inquired about samuel 3652 and
you said okay
go and join this and see what you got
how much how much does it cost
one pound but then monthly monthly 95
pound and it's
worth it yeah absolutely and and what
happens like what's the training being
like that you've received i know even
yesterday we're on a webinar together
yeah what's the training been like so
training is absolutely wonderful you
have a
one-to-one uh one-to-one sorry
one-on-one call with coachmen
coach mentor and you have online course
as well and few other options so it
depends what
what you're looking for in properties
but overall it's like a candy shop for
me
all the strategies over there yeah so
whichever you want to pick it's
i'm really happy to have that actually
are you you're
the reason people like you are the
reason that i do what i do
i appreciate it thank you it's just
incredible to say what's next then what
are your plans i know you want to get 10
more rent of rent
so get 10 more you want to get six more
yes six months how long is it going to
be before you get the next deal your
fifth rent to rent
um depends it depends it depends on
your situation so like nikola it depends
but by the end of that's our deadline
and me and my team we are aware of it
yeah so yeah so what's the plan moving
forward what's the long-term plan in
property for you
so long-term plan um by the end like i
said by the end of 2021 march
we'll have 10 properties and my manager
will be managing all these properties
and i'll be moving in br
okay you're going to be buying houses
buying them refurbishing them
refinancing them renting them exactly
yeah
and you're now 22 i've no doubt by 30
years old you're gonna be a millionaire
if not
if not way before then if not way before
then
what would be your biggest piece of
advice someone watching this maybe
someone who's young guy hungry
perhaps hasn't got a lot of money like
you didn't have a lot of money what will
be your advice what are the next steps
they need to do to get started in their
property journey
so the main thing is you need to
surround with them like-minded people
yeah that's the main thing
for me actually and that's what i want
to suggest actually that's the main
thing you need to
surround yourself with like-minded
people mm-hmm and there's a one saying
if if you're four of your friends
smoking you'll be the next one
yeah so like that is so true
so true your environment is you become
an environment yeah
how did your environment change then
over the over the last year or so how's
your environment changed
so like i said um when i was back in
foxton i have my colleagues around me
and they were like don't take risk just
focus on your job whatever doing
you're good over here and i wasn't happy
i was unhappy i was looking for
something more
actually so i can help my family i can
yeah and i started like like i said
after crash course
we had a group chat so from there we
started motivating each other
and we have and i just searched my other
few books
and from there yeah yeah that's so good
and as well
you know now you're a massive
inspiration to so many people
i hope so absolutely i mean what was it
that made you decide to come on windows
on a wednesday what made you apply to
come on this year
so like i said you are the only person
who introduced me in the property world
and it would be absolutely
great opportunity for me to be in front
of you and talking with you so yeah i
can't miss this no way
incredible and i'm so glad to be sat
with you also to meet your wife
oh yeah as well you're so young to have
all these properties and a wife
i mean geez she's an incredible lady
though yeah
you've got and i think it's it's it's
really really helpful to have someone
you're talking about environment the
fact that you've got you know your wife
behind you
yeah encouraging you is such a massive
blessing and i would agree with that
about environment if you've got
you know dampen you said show me your
friends and i'll show you your future
you know you need good people around you
yeah um and you need
not only good people around you but to
be confident you need to have the
knowledge
and you did that you got the knowledge
you got the people and you went worked
hard
yes and deserve every success that
you've got the same crash course that
you did
yeah um we've now put online because of
the pandemic
i'll leave a link in the description but
what would you say to somebody that was
thinking about enrolling onto the
property investors crash course
so what i say just stop thinking much
about anything else just
go and log in over there and you'll find
much of a much about the property over
there and you
you'll get a clear tools and strategy
what to do next in property journey
amazing well listen nick real pleasure
anything you need any time
hit me up yeah sure as a 365 member i'll
i'll be happy to help you guys i hope
you enjoyed that i think you'll agree
nick is an absolute legend
drop a nice comment below for nick and
also if you want to see more videos like
this i'm going to leave a whole playlist
there's over 100 interviews
that i've done with my students that had
their lives completely changed
by investing in property successfully if
you want to see more interviews
like nick's check out the whole playlist
right here the whole list
also if you want to learn a bit more
about the crash course i'll leave a link
in the description where you can do the
property investors crash course that
nick did i think you might also need to
subscribe so subscribe
right here thank you so much for
watching i'll see you next time